One of the best ways of gathering data for date
science projects is through the use of APIs. Now,
API stands for Application Programming Interface
and it's something that allows computer programs
to talk to each other. There's a lot of them that
operate within your operating system directly,
but it's also a way of accessing web data and
pulling in data live from multiple sources.
The most common API used in data science is going
to be what is called a REST API where REST stands
for Representational State Transfer and that's the
software architectural style of the worldwide web.
What we're going to do with REST APIs is
access data on a webpage via HTTP and the
data that we get is usually going to be in the
JSON or Java Script Object Notation format.
What's nice about this is that by using this
REST API, we can send data directly from that
webpage into other programs for analysis.
Also, REST APIs are language agnostic.
Some of the most popular APIs are Social APIs.
Facebook for example has information like that.
Twitter has a very common API and
you can get data from Twitter.
Google Talk is one of the most popular. Foursquare
and SoundCloud are also very popular social APIs.
You can build applications that connect
with these social networks directly.
In some situations, you can pull the data in for a
data science project. Also, very common are visual
APIs such as Google Maps or Youtube or AccuWeather
is very common, and so is Pinterest and Flickr.
Let me give you a brief example of
a very, very simple API through R.
I'm going to get some data from a website called
Ergast, which is for automobile racing data. And
here is what you see if you go to Ergast.com. It's
not much but if you click on that link, it'll take
you to the developer API that has information
about Formula One races from 1950 to 2014.
All you have to do is create a URL. I'm
going to do a particular search for the
people who won in 1957. This is my data in JSON
format, the people who won each race in 1957.
Now that I know what the URL is, I can go to R.
I'm going to use a package called jsonlite,
which is a way of accessing JSON data from the
web along with its dependency, curl, which is for
URLs. If you don't have those installed already,
you'll want to use install packages and I'll
use require here to get jsonlite loaded.
It loads curl by default. Then what I'm going to
do is I take that URL from earlier, which is right
here, and I use the command from JSON and feed
it into an object called F1 for Formula One. Now,
if you want to see what's in there, it's a
list object. And so that means that it's really
big and just lots and lots of text. But it is
structured the same way we saw earlier. In fact,
I'm going to pull up the structure here and this
is a way of indicating the nested structure.
But what I'm going to do is I'm going to get
a piece of that list from the overall object
F1 and I'm going to go down a level to
MR data to another level, race tables,
and so on until I get to driver and I'm going to
feed that into an object called driver. And then,
I'll get the column names for that. There's seven
columns, I'm going to take four of them and put
them in a different order and then here are
the first five drivers listed in this data set.
We have the first name, the last name, Juan
Fangio who won the first race from Argentina,
one of the greatest drivers ever. And so what
we have here is wonderful way of accessing this
structured JSON data from the web and feeding
it into R so we can use it in our own analyses.
In conclusion, APIs make
structured web data easy to get.
You can get that data and put it directly
into the program you're using for analysis.
APIs are one of the best tools for data
science in terms of retrieving data that's
structured and can be incorporated into your
analysis to get the insights that you need.